hello and welcome to this video playing
G Bianchi okay going for some classical
opening yeah let's be rock solid and see
what the other guys doing mostly they
play d4 yeah for a Catalan or be 3 or
that one okay here Quincy to is early
maybe I cannot let's gain some space him
so bishes but Quincy to is not essential
in a bologna type of structure no it's
not clear that he that this is a ping
great spot for the Queen we'll see what
happens preventing before yet 95 this is
a typical way of handling this
especially after I've played a 5 it's
okay not much that I can do about this
f6 possibly Ruby five but I've got nine
to see 7s that's so great okay here's
some not doing any of that okay if I go
if five he might have f4 it is an idea
yeah my setup is very ambitious and
might as well backfire it's a known type
of procedure against this kind of
opening here it's got the Queen on c2
but it doesn't really make a whole lot
of a difference night is often going to
eat six and possibly to c5 this is where
I'm heading also looking to make f1 as
possible or less attractive let's say ok
still plays it I really thought that was
close to prevent a tonight to array six
but why it seems not yeah he doesn't he
doesn't believe it it just is any
problem ok let's see what happens those
benoni structures are notoriously
difficult to understand and I have
problems to understand them I really
have ok so what about this now if I go
Queen to h4 very as usual I'm playing in
a very simple kind of mellow and
sometimes it's too simple but it doesn't
look so bad ok my bishop 1c8 maricon AAA
those pieces are not great mm yeah look
f6 g6 is what I'm thinking about still
yeah let's let's go down I wonder if
Bishop yeah this is a move for him maybe
it is push it over to g3 yeah that is
that is a move ok so what to do here
yeah something simplistic like h5 sh3
that's not good now and you can I need
to move we need to use my queen side
somehow I that was probably weird idea
to that Queen maneuvers here that's also
Bishop f3 coming apt imply that well
look at six was extremely naive even
Queen a Forza is an interesting just
looking at e8 and everything
we should be 700 trades also night
squares are somewhat shaky but at least
my queen then gets to be more okay Wow
well I don't like that okay so and still
cannot take on their forum can do this
for 20 x g three ideas Queen g2 probably
hmm yes yeah I should have paid more
attention to this my back rank looks
very scary very scary yeah I can take
out for here just wonder if it is any
good not my dear for Bishop takes Queen
takes out mmm there are night
discoveries but how dangerous are they I
don't see it don't see it currently
temps I have to take it I mean I don't
have to but I don't see why it wouldn't
work at the moment which is probably my
own problem and I really don't see why
it works cram
95 maybe maybe 95 this is what I'm
missing Keeks takes 95 yes ah stupid
stuff 95 is winning for what I have no
move Bishop takes if I that's even made
on aid so that's the big hole of that
and a simple one now you will find that
ah stupid stuff now my maneuvers here
with rooks and I was probably just a
little bit weird 95 so we know pretty
simple when I actually I should have
read seen that I looked at 95 yard of
course it's very simple now awful simply
awful cannot even take with the Pope
bishop it with the bishop I mean this is
the worst part time warning yeah just a
rubbish game really okay black resins
absolutely awful play I don't know maybe
the computer I mean I'm actually likes
my position here but this is so
unnatural everything and kind of like
the position at all
and I take safe was just terrible yeah i
was i was seeing that this is not work
life goes on that well yeah it says
thanks yeah they're just silly to
overlook 95 pretty pretty awful it's a
very complicated kind of position but
what I should have done is to simply
play for more ammonius go for more mon
ESP set up that now look over and so on
mnet's is just not a great idea the
engine wants to play this move just
giving this pawn I can play for this for
g5 oops sorry head1 g5 yeah maybe
something like that the way a plate that
was just very unnatural it was the kind
of kind of unnatural play that gets you
in trouble with this with the big back
ring and so on it's not like objectively
bad maybe but it's it gets you into
those situation where you can blunder
because there is not a good harmony in
the position the computer wants to do
this clearing with about equal play it's
just a pretty wise decision to cover the
back rank and term it's it's equal ish
95 I can take chicks at c5 it's very
tough this position it's not equal in
the incense of nothing happens it's just
this dynamics and probably I'm okay
there according to the carpet yeah
didn't like that didn't like that game
it was very unnatural play on the in so
in some kind of way a form yeah maybe he
has to maybe has to to get some activity
it wasn't terrible for him or anything
i'm just saying i was surprised that it
was played this is also a good idea not
get the Queen there on the King side
here we have much easier way to develop
with Bishop d7 Bishop c6 this
actually good yeah just just keep
everything harmonious and not have the
Queen running around there offside
engine actually wants to do this but but
then I have much easier development then
with the Queen out on each form the pre
knowledge flow is just yeah kind of
showing off and doing nothing that's
much much better much better no position
is this is tough computer things i'm
somewhat better here but it's not it's
just very very young unclear and sharp
in a way and anything can happen i just
have to avoid this kind of uh pneumonias
position with the week back rank okay
well thanks for watching